can I ask you a few questions
soliciting a minor would you say that
you are enjoying yourself and having fun
having a moderate amount of fun or
having no fun and no enjoyment things
bureaucracy nerds asked during sex
somehow makes it into the episode I mean
that's some grade-a fraud right there
right
the Leslie Knope I know and love would
never stand for such shoddy research
technically he's not stuck he's sleeping
in the slide kids when I first tell
people that I work in the government
they say oh the government the
government stinks the lines are too long
in the DMV but now things have changed
indeed when people bring up the issues
they have with the government right now
DMV is never even mentioned there many
things that have trumped that issue so
to speak
why is this shot she's been on the
playground for this entire cold open and
then they throw in a single second of
this pool scene for this speedy speedo
joke I'm guessing they shot an entire
other scene and didn't want to lose it
but it's jarring it doesn't work and
it's jarring also it doesn't work grain
is not being petted by Russell Crowe in
this scene this is a great thing for you
guys to see here Leslie is talking to
the documentary camera crew that for
some reason is filming this be in our
departments every move look even beyond
the never justified reasons for shooting
the dock the show itself just doesn't
work as a mockumentary in the office or
Modern Family you at least had
characters where the cameras elevated
their need to perform for the audience
but here everyone is either too sincere
or too apathetic to even care that there
are cameras around so it just comes off
as lazy exposition it's locked
hahaha get it she was excited to go in
and then it was locked and she couldn't
go in humor thank you so much for coming
what an amazing turnout I get based on
this pan to the shot of the audience
this is supposed to go against what
Leslie just said but have you been to a
City public forum this is borderline
sold out so take two if they were able
to arrange with someone getting into
another room wouldn't have been just as
easy to get someone to turn the lights
back on in the auditorium
in her sea she's near me falling to her
knees sorry I sometimes black out and
sing Counting Crows
it's really not that odd round here so
your boyfriend fell down into this pit
right interesting question but I'm more
curious to find out how this newspaper
article wound up in Anne's hands since
it clearly wasn't there when she stood
up this guy's pretty serious you guys
living together leslie knope allows this
to go on for some time
anything over twenty five dollars as a
report show continues to follow the
mockumentary blueprint of never
explaining how they get crystal-clear
audio out of every single conversation
even through solid walls
I'm from Bennett's Ville South Carolina
and what you might call a redneck
neither Tom nor the show ever indicate
any way in which this is true I mean we
never see him at a NASCAR event or an
IndyCar event sorry is that racist
committees your power committees make
things happen committees are the
lifeblood of our democratic system the
problem with a show that tries to make
boring things funny is that it too often
ends up making funny things boring I
think I read that on a motivational
poster once a boring non funny
motivational poster he's collecting them
for my memoirs here's Leslie's quote
from Wednesday oh good another show
where we're supposed to fall in love
with awful people who are awful at their
jobs yay honestly I'm surprised the show
even lasted long enough to get a chance
to eventually be good okay read back to
me committees cover our democracy with
blood it sounded better when I said it
there is no way Leslie thinks this is
what she said how dumb do they think we
think she thinks we are well if you want
something done in this town you call
mark brendanawicz
but only for 30 episodes 2009 when the
idea of locker-room politics was
hilarious instead of infuriating they
let writers just write the jokes they
didn't have to wait they could do any
joke they wanted they just grabbed them
by the punchline mark and I it's
complicated noop Leslie no oh my god you
know what real interesting tactic making
your male lead and possible love
interest for your female lead such a
deal wipe right out of the gate
furthermore I'm calling 100% BS that
marks dumbass wouldn't recall a
one-night stand with anyone especially
someone who's worked side-by-side with
for the last five years
I mean I don't think anybody in
government actually cares about
somewhere else I'm trying to watch TV
and we can even hear the TV but only
after you interrupt so that it doesn't
ruin the joke good thing those audio
engineers had the humor setting
calibrated on that boom mic Shakespeare
in the Park it's really not that big of
a pitch Boston public would be excellent
at TV since yeah yeah she's going to
fall and we're going to have a hearty
chuckle but there are so many better
choices to walk down to the pit
including whatever route Ann takes when
she goes down to help her in a minute
this show seems to confuse Leslie insane
optimism with insane stupidity cheating
on your waffles is that a travel pillow
around your neck it's quite possible mr.
Ronald Ulysses Swanson is the only
reason the show even made it to season
two and for that fact alone cine shall
grant the ned i think that all
government is a waste of taxpayer money
fighting the bureaucratic hand that
wastefully feeds you I'm gonna leave
before you change your mind
character says he will take a look at
something and then throw said something
in the trash when the other person
leaves the room cliche the upskirt photo
awesome
I hate Tom I just really hate Tom have I
mentioned how much I hate Tom hugging at
work on Halloween
she was dressed up as Batman not Batgirl
Batman Wow outrageous tell me more about
this supposedly binary Batman and I
convinced her to go stop a crime that
was watching outside you mean there was
just some random crime going on outside
and tiny Pawnee that Leslie Knope
stopped or are you just saying you
convinced her there was a crime that
needed to be stopped and there wasn't
one I'm sending this until I see video
or it didn't happen so I'm gonna make a
vow wait a second did this documentary
interview just cut to a secondary
closeup handheld shot I mean that's some
crafty docu shooting right there what's
next handing Leslie an iPad to watch
someone talk smack about why they have
to break up the Parks and Rec team after
six championship seasons on one hand
Bobby Knight is exactly the kind of
person Swanson would have on his wall
but on the other hand Bobby Knight also
episode does not contain a Kris or Ben
or sense of humor
I'd say in a given week I probably only
do about 15 minutes of real actual work
did you know the cinemas and writers
have podcast checkouts in cast man
behind the sins by searching for cinema
sins wherever you listen to podcasts to
get a Libyan I need more firepower I
need bigger guns oh hi mark you crazy
old polish person what would you say I
told you that I was thinking about
turning it into a huh there's no way I
seem to have fallen down a cliff I'm
still alive but I'm very badly injured
can't believe you fell into that's
awesome it's not awesome Andy dance-off
fro me and you know Kelly Clarkson